well continuing on the last minute
Christmas preparations we check in with
Chef Jeff Jackson from Smith's Food and
Drug the sponsors of this segment he is
sharing an apple pie recipe taken from
the Kroger making memories cookbook and
coloring book
hello everybody I'm Chef Jack from
Smith's it's the holiday season it's a
great time to make memories with your
family and food is a great vehicle to do
that now Smith's and Kroger have given
us a great tool to help us with that
it's a little cookbook slash coloring
book and it's got characters that you
may have recognize before in the
commercials but inside there are recipes
for turkey and also for pie I'm going to
show you how to make that pie today
super easy I'm going to use a couple of
shortcuts and one thing I want to do is
it's a brown butter and cinnamon brown
butter I made this earlier when you're
Browning butter make sure to melt it
slowly and then kind of wait for it to
kind of foam up and you'll smell it get
really nutty and start have brown bits
but it will burn quickly so once it gets
to that point take it off of the heat
that's what I have here see all those
little brown bits in there as well
that's perfect brown butter let's get to
the apples I like to use Granny Smith
apples and I don't peel mine you can
peel yours what I do is just cut them
right off the core like so
and then once they're off of the core
then I can just slice them into my
perfect thin slices leaving the skin on
because I don't like that step cut them
thin get them in our Bowl and we've got
our brown butter in there so now it's
the flavoring I have some brown sugar
that's going to go in there
and then some cloves of cinnamon
cornstarch and ginger the cornstarch is
in there to kind of help thicken it up
and make it really gooey like you're
expecting an apple pie to be so we'll go
ahead and mix those up okay they're
perfect and ready to go let me take my
gloves off and then I'll show you what
we're going to do with the pie crust I
don't like making pie crust but you can
buy pie crust that are pre-made it's a
great time saving tool you just take
them out and unroll them and
get your pie pan ready to go and have it
be room temperature a little bit if you
try to get them out of the package
without letting them sit room
temperature then they kind of break
apart and we don't want that so we're
going to press our dough in there like
so
we're going to put our apples in there
and then lastly we're going to create a
lattice top my oven is preheating to
350. our asset actually it's at 425. I'm
Excuse me it's 425 oven but to make that
lattice top simply take the other pie
crust and we're going to cut it into
strips
okay so I've cut my pie dough into
strips and then you just create a
lattice so it's basically over and under
over and under and over and under you'll
get the hang of it as as you do each one
it's pretty easy to go and then you'll
just trim the trim the edges and it'll
look look nice and beautiful okay so I
form my last it doesn't look perfect but
that's okay we don't have to be
professional pie makers and then get
some egg wash which is just egg and
water brush it on the top to help it
brown it will go in a 425 degree oven
for 20 minutes at that point put the the
pie protector if you've got one or just
put foil around the edges to prevent
over Browning but then what you should
have is this beautiful pie that comes
out looks beautiful make sure to let it
cool probably for about three or four
hours before serving you can find all
these ingredients at your local Smiths
and remember during the holidays it
doesn't matter what you make just so
you're making memories so happy holidays
everyone will see you next time bye
everyone
thank you to Smith's Food and Drug for
sponsoring this segment they have
several locations across the valley for
more information visit
smithsfoodanddrug.com